hallo YouTube chest lowers muffins
this is grunge in here welcome to the
17th episode of dirty chest tricks I am
continuing my turkey reputa against a
French defense which arises after the
Mordor efore a6 and here my
recommendation is you play the two
lights attack system which start with
the move Knight to f3 and after the
usual French move defy you are going to
continue with the move Knight to c3 now
in my last party chess trick video I
have gone through the move c phi so if
you haven't watched that video i
strongly insist you to go and watch that
video in this episode I am going to
concentrate on Black's main other three
replies such as d 4 D captures efore and
Bishop to b4 in my next dirty Cheswick
video I am going to concentrate on the
main line which arises after the move
Knight to f6 and which is in fact the
choice of many higher ranked player but
against it I am going to show you some
of the very high profile tricks which
you can use it in official feed a rating
tournament yes you heard it right so
please don't miss that the one point I
like to mention before I start that is
in this video I'm not covering the whole
theory I am going to show you only
tricks and the opening ideas by the
white if you want to add this reputa in
your own games then I'm strongly insist
you to go through the theory section of
this line and the one of the good
resource which I can mention you over
here is this book a starting chess
opening reputa by Chris Baker where he
covered this line in detail so kindly
google it buy it and go through it okay
the first more I want to consider over
here is d4 which is a case of many
intermediate to advanced player but here
this is not a good choice by black the
simple reason is not only black is out
of his theory just early in the opening
but after the obvious move Knight to e2
black has to play very careful to avoid
some nasty tricks by white for example
the usual response over here is c5 and
here right we'll continue with the MU c3
now kinda note if black capture this
pawn
then after B capture c3 not only white
will gain a Center in the middle game
but that will give a consistent
advantage to the white so that's why
instead of capturing that pawn many
black players come up with this two
choices which in fact allow us to win
the game in the opening stage okay
number one is d3 which on the software
looks like black is cramping the white
but see yourself after Knight to f4
attacking the D pawn black has the
obvious choice that is c4 and at first
glance it looks like black is doing very
good but after just one move that is
Queen to a4 check not only white will
win the c4 pawn but once that pawn falls
then the d3 pawn also Falls and in fact
the game so pushing the D pawn is not
possible at this point at this position
probably the highest play reply against
me is Knight to c6 which on the surface
looks so good but I'm afraid this is a
big mistake
and the simple refutation is after C
captures and C captures white has this
lethal move Queen to e4 and black has
lost the bond just early in opening so
the following continuation can be like
this if Bishop to d7 then after Knight
captures Knight captures and Queen
captures white is a solid point
up and if d3 at this point then the
simplest answer is you play Knight to d4
attacking the c6 Knight and after Bishop
to d7 you can simply grab the spawn and
emerge with a winning position
the second move I want to consider over
here is D captious efore but I think
here what is more than happy to see this
line because after night captures efore
why it has a simple but very effective
plan so for example what white wants to
do is to play the mood d4 followed by
the move Bishop to b3 and if this D
polar tag then he can consolidate this
pawn via the move c3 the Queen comes to
the e2 and then white can decide either
castle long or the short and although
black has plenty of choices over here it
is the white who is having all the fun
in this line so to illustrate this I
just like to show you my best win in
this line
one of my very hiring player which is
around 2000 continued here with the move
Bishop to e7 I continue with the move d4
Esper of a plan
my opponent plays Knight to f6 and I
immediately capture this Knight my
opponent recaptured and I consolidate my
D pawn with the move c3 my opponent
castle on the Kings side and I played
the move Bishop to d3 so just in the
opening we can compare this bishop pair
with the black Bishop pair and it's
clearly indicating that white is going
to have so much fun in the middle game
okay black continue with the move b6
because he has to develop this bishop on
this diagonal
se6 pawn is blocking his view now
exactly here after some thinking I come
up with a very concrete plan some of the
moves are void is very forcing one so
here I continue with the move Queen to
c2 attacking at 7 my opponent defended
with the move g6 now I played another
forcing move that is Bishop to b4
hitting the rook so my approach is to
play the move c6 and now when you have a
sitting target on g8 you need to open up
some lines for your pieces and easiest
attacking model in most of the cases yep
you guessed it h4 so idea is to play H
file and open the line for the rook my
opponent didn't like it so he played
h phi himself but again this is turnout
as a serious mistake i continued very
energetic over here I played Bishop to
g5 and my idea is to now sacrificing on
g6 as bishop cannot retrieve to the g7
square my opponent defended with the MU
King to g7 now I create another threat
with the move Queen to d2 now if my
opponent has played the move rook to h8
then Knight to e5 a very strong move so
in the game my opponent decided to play
the move rook to e8 so he want to keep
his rook active but it's not going to
happen for a while I continue with the
move Queen to f4
so pressurizing f6 and my opponent
decided to resolve the center by
capturing the bishop now here after a
long thinking I think I come up with the
most accurate move that is H captures g5
and you can already see the pathetic
position of black not only none of the
black pcs has been developed but his
King will be surrounded by many white
pieces here finally my opponent Dell off
his piece Bishop to b7 but I think it's
too little too late his idea is to play
the move Knight to d7
but after White's next reply that is
Knight to e5 I think black has some
serious issues on both the points such
as c6 and the f7 point after some
thinking my opponent played the move
Queen to c7 which in fact decide the
game I wonder if you can spot it okay I
hope you find this more order that is
Queen to f6 check King to g8 and now can
you see why it's next move
congratulations if you see this move
that is rock to h5 boom hahaha so White
has a little idea of checkmating black
king and black doesn't have any option
black has to accept this piece sacrifice
and after this the second dazzling
sacrifice yup you guessed it bishop to
at 7 check kindly note if King to affect
then Knight to g6 is a checkmate so
black has to forcefully accept this
piece
sacrifice but after this night to f7 and
blacking is going to be mated in three
moves you can try all different moves by
black one more move is played by a black
my opponent plays King to g8 but after
g6 that is no escaping
so after D captures efore the resulting
position is quite fun to play as white
now let's look at the third option by
black that is Bishop to b4 which can be
played by many French whenever player
but here as White has not committed the
d4 I think this is a big mistake by
black now there are two lines I can
recommend you over here the first line
is starting with the move a three here
black has two options if Bishop to e7
then after he captures and each captures
white can simply play the move d4 and
it's very funny that we enter into the
French exchange variation where not only
this Bishop is badly placed on e7 it
should be rather on d6 but white has an
extra temp on a tree which will help to
play b4 in one go so this is a very good
position for white if black decided to
capture this Knight and thinks that he
can win a pawn after D captures efore
well he is completely wrong the simple
refutation is you exchange the Queen and
after King captures you play the move
Knight to g5 which will not only regain
the pawn after King to e7 and 94 but
kindly note White has a bishop pair and
a wonderful leading development so if
you check this position with any
computer it will give white a good
advantage I think against Bishop to b4
the most trickiest line which I can
recommend you over here is you play the
movie 5 and if black plays here Knight
to e7 then you can continue with the MU
a3 but what I found with my own
experience is many French will never
player they just automatically continue
with the move c5 and this is exactly we
are hoping for the simplest repetition
is Knight to be Phi
and the night is jumping on d6 and there
are hardly any piece which can stop it
so black has this Force reply now that
is c4 so stopping Knight to d6 but now
White has this wonderful move c3
attacking the bishop and black has to
decide what he is going to do I use this
position two times in my games in the
first game my lower ranked opponent
played the move Bishop to e7 I continue
with the mood d3 and now he attacked my
night with the moon a six but I think
after the move Knight to d5 where not
only this night is wonderfully placed in
the center of the board
but g8 Knight is having a severe
difficulty for developing so this line
is quite good for white and it justifier
because the game finished very quickly
my opponent plays the obvious move which
is B Phi so consolidating the center but
just one move and black is losing can
you spot it yes it's a four so we are
attacking B Phi and there is no easy way
to defend this fall so here the base
response which is played by my opponent
that is b4 but after D capture c4 b
capture c3b capture c3 pawn captures c4
Bishop to c4 Queen to c7 and Queen to e2
not only white emerge with an extra pawn
but still black has to solve the issue
where he's going to Dell of his Knight
and second game where my opponent was
really high rated he played the most
critical move over here that is Essex
counter attacking my knight no matter we
know where this Knight belong so I
played the move Knight to d4 and now as
usual if Bishop goes to the e7 then
black will have some problem developing
the clean side so in the game my
opponent played the vise move that is
Bishop to e5 and I continue with the
movie 3 now be five against fails in
such a position the simple reason is
same idea which we have used earlier
that is a4
and the best continuation over here is
b4 afterwards pawn captures Bishop
captures and pawn captures white emerge
with a pawn advantage so obviously in my
game my opponent doesn't play that he
played the obvious mu that is C captures
b3 I capture with my a pawn and now he
played the move Knight to e7 so this is
pretty much most likely move order you
are going to face because what black
wants to do is to quickly castle on the
King side and then start doing counter
tacking on white Queen side well I am
afraid our tricks are not over yet White
has this little move Bishop to d3 and
black cannot cancel that's right black
cannot castle why okay here is why if
black castle then can you guess where
its next move nope you are wrong
it's not bishop at seven there is a
stronger move then Bishop 287 that is
rook to a5 well what's the idea the idea
is to draw black Queen on the other side
of the board and now you do Bishop to h7
kinda not f king to a shade then Knight
to g5 and followed by Queen mu which
will almost kill the black so here black
has to accept this piece sacrifice that
is king - at seven afterwards we are
going to play Knight to g5 check and now
if King to g8 then Queen to h5 is a very
strong move
so in this game my opponent continued
with the King March that is king to g6
attacking my knight no matter the
typical move in this kind of scenario
that is Queen to g4 so we are trying to
get a discover attack to the black king
my opponent is pointed over here with
the mu F 5 but I think this is too much
ambitious
I played the most accurate mu in this
position that is Queen to h4 and now
there are some serious checkmate threats
on the black King in the desperation my
opponent plays Queen to e1 which I think
allow me to finish him very quickly now
before I show you I like you to pause
this video and
find out a Czech meeting sequence okay I
hope you find this Mordor that is Queen
Chad king captures and now the super
accurate move yup Knight to f3 no matter
where King goes for example in this game
my opponent plays King to a4 but after
Queen to h5 it's a checkmate
so if black castle early at this point
then he will be in a huge trouble so
some of you might think well what
happens if black plays the move at 6
which is obvious choice of many French
player before they do castle well
against this we have a very sneaky trick
and it start with a very simple New
Castle now no matter how black respond
to this for example black and Castle
here immediately you are played Knight
to c6 and then castle but against either
of this idea why it has a very good
reply now I get a victim in this line
just before recording this video so I
like to show you this gift where my
opponent continued with the move castle
on the Kings side
I played the move Bishop to b1 and now
he continued with the move Knight to c6
so at first sight it looks like black is
doing very good but after White's next
reply that is Queen to c2 whoa
so we have a bazooka looking at black
inside and I think it's going to be very
hard for black to defuse this my
opponent feel the heat immediately so he
played the move g6
I continue with the MU capturing the
knight first he recaptured with the
b-pawn
and now the obvious response d4 not only
consolidating the center but hitting
that six my opponent defended with the
move King to g7 and now no prize for
guessing White's next move which is very
obvious when you doing a King side
attack yep
you throw your H pawn so idea is too
weak black inside and then launched a
devastation there as usual my opponent
see this so he stopped himself by
playing gauge 5 but I think this is
again a serious error and which allow me
to play very aggressively so I continue
here with
Bishop to g5 now it has a simple threat
of capturing the night and then
capturing the bishop so my opponent drop
is Bishop back to the p6 I continue with
the move Bishop to f6 check and after
King to h7 I played a very sneaky but
cunning Quint we - now I don't know
whether my opponent was exhausted by his
very cramped position but he played a
very casual move that is Queen to c7
probably he wants to unpin his knight
but the end is near the first obvious
move is Knight to g5 check and my
opponent responded with the move King to
g8 and now the final puzzle of the video
take some time out and find the best
move over here for the white ok I hope
you find this move that is boom what a
wonderful mood to play on the board and
I feel very proud about this move
however black responds the next move is
checkmate that's the beauty about this
move probably the best of it if black
captured this Queen but after Bishop 2
at 7 I think your opponent is not going
to sleep at the night if you're doing
such a wonderful checkmate that's it
guys I hope you enjoy and learn
something from this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care
counter was initially introduced at the
Adelaide and it won a consolation prize
and during that time people were
thinking that this is a complete
reputation to the King's gambit are very
very amazing move by the Spassky which
is C cross V 3
at the first sight looks like very
suicidal because